Тарифи в Україні знижено на 12%,
заявив днями президент Володимир Зеленський
і пообіцяв знайти способи зменшити їх іще.
Ми вже знизили тарифи на...
12, мені здається, в цілому на 12 відсотків.
Це замало. Але це перший крок.
Ціна на газ для українців дійсно знижується вже кілька місяців поспіль.
Зокрема, за даними "Нафтогазу", порівняно з червнем,
у липні вартість блакитного палива зменшилася на 648 гривень,
або на майже 12%.
Якщо Володимир Зеленський у своїй заяві мав на увазі саме тарифи на газ,
у цій частині його слова відповідають дійсності.
Загалом, за даними українського уряду,
вартість газу для населення за три місяці
зменшилася на чверть - з 5 803 гривень
до 4 640 гривень за тисячу кубів.
Щоправда, це не кінцева роздрібна ціна,
адже вона не включає податок на додану вартість,
а також витрати на транспортування і постачання,
які встановлюються для обласних чи міськгазів
Нацкомісією з регулювання у сферах енергетики та комунальних послуг.
Чия заслуга у зниженні тарифів?
Формально на це вплинув український уряд,
запровадивши регулювання ціни на газ для населення,
коли при її формуванні враховуються глобальні тренди.
Напередодні першого зниження ціни цьогоріч у травні
прем’єр Володимир Гройсман приписував цю заслугу собі,
заявлявши, що "поставив жорстку вимогу перед "Нафтогазом".
Проте головна причина - зовнішні чинники.
Україна купує газ у Європі, а там він останнім часом рекордно подешевшав,
передусім, через теплу зиму і великий залишок у сховищах.
А також через зниження цін на нафту
і поставки дешевого зрідженого газу із США.
Утім, що буде із ціною на газ восени і взимку
і чи вдасться втримати її в опалювальний сезон на рівні серпневої,
прогнози оглядачів радше скептичні.
А те, що зниження ціни подається як досягнення нового президента,
вважають маніпуляцією. Мовляв, встановлення ціни
відбувається із запізненням на місяць,
тобто зараз на ринку спостерігаються червневі тенденції.
А оскільки тренд до зниження вартості блакитного палива на європейських ринках,
як зазначають оглядачі, вже завершився,
у серпні варто очікувати зростання ціни на газ.
Зниження ціни на газ - це подія, яку українські політики
нерідко намагаються подати як власну перемогу,
навіть якщо не мають до цього жодного стосунку.
Президент Володимир Зеленський, хоча питання тарифів
не входить до його компетенції, не став винятком.
Тарифи на газ в Україні дійсно знизилися, у цьому глава держави правий.
Однак це не заслуга його команди,
а радше наслідок трендів на світових ринках.